c'était le joyau de notre empire bay
tout d'abord b
je lis je commence
lieu de corruption ont été 6 2 tentation
cet esclave regarde comme dans un rêve
kassir et de lutte
quel est ton nom mon nom est mignon pour
survivre demain nous nous battrons un
esclave qui survit gagne sa liberté des
quatre coins de l'empiré romain
les gens affluent et vers ce lieu si on
te trouve ici avec moi cela en vaudra la
peine
et c'est la montagne
mais malgré notre puissance centre si
nous vivions dans l'ombre
d'une force plus grande encore
quoi qu'il advienne
nous serons libres ou navy
il faut gagner le port nous le ferons
ensemble
protégez vous